[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight if you've been seated in front
of a TV all day watching the unfolding
pageant and obviously we're hoping that
you were because it's our business you
know that Michael Flynn was supposed to
be sentenced today that would be for the
crime of lying to FBI agents in his
now-famous White House interview at the
very beginning of the administration for
a number of reasons you probably already
heard about none of them very
significant in the cosmic scheme of
things that sentencing has been
postponed until the new year and of
course we'll bring you the details when
that happens in the meantime though we
thought we would seize this opportunity
to take stock of all that we have
learned Michael Flynn being of course
the first major target of the mall
investigation that was all the way back
if you can believe it at the beginning
of last year 2017 so it's been just
about two years almost and the hunt for
Russian spies on our soil has not slowed
down it has metastasized into something
vast and remarkable it's now practically
its own agency of government there now
we think this is right there could be
more but what we could find are a half a
dozen separate Russia investigations now
being conducted by the Justice
Department that does not even count the
separate congressional increases at four
or five maybe more who knows and then of
course nearly a hundred percent of the
attention of every news organization in
Washington almost everyone so what have
we learned after all that time and all
that money and all that attention well
we know that the Russians spent a total
of let's check the math $4,700 on Google
ads during the 2016 election trying to
buy a car for that we all saw that
jerome corsi and george papadapolis two
people you probably had never heard of
before likely did something bad like
misremembering dates or emails though
apparently neither one of them spied for
anybody that's what we've learned we've
also learned that and people are not
noting this but we thought it'd be worth
pointing out virtually every issue that
led voters unexpectedly to support
Donald Trump in 2016 remains as of now
unresolved in some cases not even
addressed that would include the decline
of the American middle class the drop in
life expectancy the opioid crisis our
unsecured southern border
crushing student loan debt the global
dominance of China the quagmire and
Afghanistan infrastructure healthcare
costs we could go any of the little
things you haven't heard a lot about any
of that lately
the news acres have not had time to tell
you about any of that because they're
too busy shouting self-righteously about
michael Flynn he lied he lied they by
contrast never lie because they're good
people unlike Michael Flynn who lied so
I guess the point is there's been a cost
to our rush of fixation years later we
may look back and wonder what happened
during the last two years how did
everybody in America with an Ivy League
education simultaneously go insane in
the space of a single year was there
some kind of mass poisoning was it
arrghh 'it is amit happened in medieval
france maybe maybe that's what happened
we're gonna let historians sort that out
we're not really sure for now all we
know for certain is that the people in
charge have lost it they really have and
if you don't believe it listen to them
explain the intricacies of the Russia
conspiracy they're mesmerized by it
it's a tale so complex so riddled with
internal contradictions it sounds like
an Eastern religion only they really
understand it but they mean it and they
do understand it to them Russia is the
touchstone is the comprehensive theory
of everything consider what happened for
example less done in cable news and it
really could have been any night on
cable news MSNBC CNN take your pick we
just happen to be watching last night
around 11:00 when this happened so we're
bringing it to you tonight because it's
interesting and it tells you a lot by
the way this is from the most serious
news program that NBC offers on cable
it's called the 11th hour there are two
people in the segment we're about to
show you the first is a man called
Malcom Nance
now Nantz identify himself as a 35-year
veteran of counterintelligence work
whatever that means his most recent book
is called the plot to hack America was a
national bestseller thanks to heavy
promotion from MSNBC the second man
you're about to see is Brian Williams
who of course needs no introduction
who was the anchor of the NBC Nightly
News back when that meant something
william says widely regarded as a good
guy by people who know him and he's
absolutely in Washington anyway is
thought of as one of the smartest people
in the news business the point is these
are not cooks on late-night radio they
are considered highly impressive
but keep that in mind as you watch this
Williams opens a segment by explaining
that Russian disinformation teams have
been working to divide America and
convince the population among other
totally implausible things that Jim
Comey and Robert Muller might have
political agendas ridiculous right
Williams asked Malcolm Nance to comment
on that proposition and Nance says this
what Russia has done here and where the
true brilliance of this intelligence
operation comes from is way back in the
early 2000s the Russian military
conducted a strategic study and started
carrying out a disinformation plan in
which they said that instead of carrying
out kinetic warfare against your enemies
the best thing we can do is create a
disinformation of frame around that
nation to the point where over time as
we are constantly tearing them apart and
feeding them with false information they
would actually welcome an invasion huh
oh wait wait a second here this is what
we in the news business call news so for
nearly 20 years the Russians have been
building a disinformation frame around
the United States
what's a disinformation frame and how
does it manage to brainwash an entire
population so thoroughly that they
welcome foreign invasion I mean that's
got to be the most powerful mind control
device in human history more detail
please this really this is the part of
the interview where the anchor politely
interrupts the guest and asked him to
explain what the hell he's talking about
but Williams does not do that he just
lets Malcolm Nance keep talking so
Malcolm Nance does keep talking so
Russia has done that to the United
States and it began way before 2016 as a
matter of fact the earliest references I
have with relation to Donald Trump shows
that it started back in 2011 with Maria
boo Tina and the NRA contacts contacts
with the fundamentalist Christian right
and the alt-right in the United States
Russia
pushing these disinformation themes then
then in 2013 they stood up the Russian
Federation internet research agency
which built all of these memes and
tropes which became the cruise missiles
of fake news and disinformation designed
to do what it did today take one third
of the United States population and make
them refused to believe what they see
before their very eyes and may have
elected a president in the process holy
smokes this is a tsunami of news it
turns out that Donald Trump's collusion
with Russia began years before any of us
suspected way back in 2011 here's the
confusing part in 2011 by all outward
appearances Trump was still a pretty
conventional New York liberal he went to
David Letterman to read the top 10 list
he endorsed gun control it was all a
cover a sophisticated ruse as Malcolm
Nance reveals Trump was in fact busy
plotting with the NRA Christian
fundamentalists and the all right now
keep in mind this was years before there
was such a thing as the alt-right but
that's just how stealthy this operation
was even the steel dossier missed it
sort of the rest of us so that's not
surprising since his Malcolm Nance's
explained thanks to Russian brainwashing
one-third of the US population can no
longer perceive reality that's Malcolm
Nance's position what would you do if
somebody repeated those exact same words
do you want a city bus you'd likely be
worried at the very least you'd probably
switch seats not brian williams he'd
moved closer williams didn't seem to
consider Nance's explanation strange in
the slightest he was deeply impressed by
it
Williams asked how the Russians could
have pulled off an operation this
extensive without the willing help of
American accomplices of course that's
Nance had an answer to that keep in mind
as you watch this clip that we have not
edited the tape in any way this aired
verbatim last night on MSNBC watch they
have played on the themes of far-right
conspiracy theorists from the 1960 the
John Birch Society a sideline group
you know and the farthest extremes of
the libertarian parties they have
amplified racism to the point where the
alt-right steve bannon's own creation of
gamers is now of the wholly owned
subsidiary of the trump campaign and our
believers in David Duke the Ku Klux Klan
Richard and Richard Spencer the neo-nazi
and Robert Spencer the islamaphobe to
the point where they're mainstreamed
this is how effective this information
warfare campaign has been carried out
and let me tell you this report shows
how they went after to suppress the
african-american vote and there is no
doubt in my mind or anybody else's in
the intelligence community that doesn't
believe that it took American citizens
to assist them in really getting down to
where these voters were who needed to be
suppressed Wow
so in case you weren't transcribing that
as you watch let's bottom-line it for
you the Russia conspiracy just expanded
to include a bewildering array of new
figures these would include the John
Birch Society the KKK David Duke people
who play online video games
Steve Bannon a religion blogger named
Robert Spencer and others collectively
their goal was not simply to elect
Donald Trump but to hurt
african-americans why would Russian
intelligence want to do that you might
ask well if you have to ask you're
probably working for Vladimir Putin too
so shut up it goes without saying that
all of this is completely insane there's
no evidence to support any of it it is
not true worse than that it's
irresponsible keep in mind this aired on
a division of NBC News so some large
number of people are likely going to
believe it
they'll go to sleep worrying about the
invisible disinformation frame that
surrounds their country and the
resurgence of the John Birch Society and
they'll wake up a little more convinced
that anyone who disagrees with them is a
tool of a foreign power because that is
the real message here and of this whole
conspiracy there's no other side of the
debate
there's only Russian propaganda to a
certain sort of fragile liberal that's
probably comforting to know but it's a
lie in fact it's its own form of
propaganda no news organization should
traffic in garbage like this news
anchors exist
push back against nutty claims like
these Brian Williams bought them
completely Wow
Malcolm Nance this is why we ask you all
the time to come on this broadcast scary
stuff but it needs to be said needs to
be heard thank you sir so much for
joining us once again it needs to be
said it needs to be heard this is why we
asked you to come on this broadcast save
that video future generations won't
believe it